votre soirée spéciale municipal se
poursuit en bourgogne sur france3
résultats et réactions des principaux
candidats nous partons tout de suite à
montceau-les-mines où nous attend didier
mathus battu ce soir à
montceau-les-mines par marie claude
jarrot bonsoir didier mathus
comment analysez vous cette défaite ce
soir je crois que la dynamique de droite
était très très puissante à montceau
comme ailleurs et que on a assisté un
phénomène un peu particulier par contre
qui est un report massif des voix du
front national sur la candidate ump que
pour le moment je ne m'explique pas mais
qui est indiscutable dans les résultats
et qui a donc largement marqué cette
évolution du second tour n'a pas pris
selon vous à montceau pour vous
expliquer cette défaite quand même après
trois mandats parce que les mères
implanté résiste plutôt mieux que les
autres vous vous étiez quelqu'un de très
implanté qu'est ce qui fait que voilà le
vent du boulet est passé par là je crois
qu'il ya eu la configuration du premier
tour avec une liste fn une liste
dissidente du front de gauche qui nous a
affaiblis au premier tour et qui a donc
créé une dynamique en faveur de la
droite pour le second tour donc voilà
j'en prends acte peut-être y at-il aussi
un phénomène de mise en cause
personnelle bout de trois mandats c'est
peut-être possible donc j'en tirerai
toutes les conséquences et vous allez
rester dans l'opposition
je vais me donner quelques jours pour
réfléchir à la meilleure stratégie
possible pour la gauche
à montceau moi en tout cas je suis très
heureux d'avoir travaillé pendant 19 ans
pour ma ville parce que j'y suis né j'y
ai grandi je la connais intimement donc
c'est déjà une belle histoire une belle
aventure que d'avoir pu faire ce travail
pour mes concitoyens pendant 19 ans mais
vous nous dites pas ce soir si vous
siégerez ou pas au conseil municipal
nous en discuterons dans les jours qui
viennent
merci didier mathus en direct de
montceau-les-mines à propos de
montceau-les-mines dit mathus évoquait
justement le front national lille lyon
en noir au ces réactions recueillies
tout à leur écoute et lilian noirot
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
élection municipale à montceau les mines
en 2014 tout d'abord donc la défaite de
monsieur mathus
on vous envoie pertinemment le
ras-le-bol quant aux éléments ce lien
vers la politique dévastatrice de
monsieur mathus mais également face à
l'élan d'espoir de bon sens que les
monceaux de liens nous ont apporté en
votant pour la liste donc j'ai l'honneur
de mener donc le front national
s'implante à montceau les mines il
s'enracine
donc nous avons un élu au conseil
municipal de montceau-les-mines donc
c'est une victoire pour nous nous
souhaitions être au deuxième tour nous
avons dépassé les 10%
nous sommes et nous avons réussi à
battre monsieur mathus donc nous sommes
plutôt fiers de nos résultats nous
sommes fiers d'eux d'avoir apporté des
élus front national
à montceau-les-mines donc c'est une
victoire pour nous lilian noirot c'est
vous qui siègeraient j'imagine au
conseil municipal
vous ne resterez pas les bras croisés
j'imagine vous avez envie de re et
d'être actif ça sera pas compliqué avec
un seul siège
non je ne pense pas car je serai un
orchidoclaste au sein de ce conseil
municipal de montceau les mines qui en
aura naturellement besoin face à un
système ump s caché qui a été sanctionné
ce soir donc nous sommes nous l'avons
toujours dit durant notre campagne nous
serons des élus avec force de
proposition mais également des
véritables élus d'opposition donc sur
divers points nous apportons nos
contributions également nos propositions
sur sur tous les aspects de la vie
municipale et plus globalement le front
national s'implante dans les mairies
avec cette élection municipale avec ces
élections municipales tout à fait donc
aux dernières connaissances
robert ménard est élu à béziers david
rachline à fréjus également donc le
florian philippot ce n'est pas nouvelle
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
front national qui les français nous ont
fait part de cet élan patriotique temps
de gauche comme de droite
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
front national et marine le pen l'a
rappelé je pense que ce soir l'objectif
des 1000 conseillers municipaux et plus
doit être dépassé lille et noirot pour
le front national à montceau-les-mines
nous ont rejoints et si on direct sur
france 3 bourgogne françois patriat
bonsoir açores président socialiste du
conseil régional de bourgogne et
françois sauvadet bonsoir bonsoir
président dudit du conseil général de la
côte-d'or et vice président national de
l'udps et avant de débattre de discuter
avec vous des résultats concernant à
nouveau la saône et loire elle a besoin
oui et la ville de bourg on si on
premier lieu le maire ps sortant
jean-paul drapier perd son siège au
profit d'une candidate de gauche qui
puisait son ancienne adjointe édith
gueugneau remporté le scrutin avec 46%
des suffrages la base la page j'ai un
voisin est tournée à charnay-lès-mâcon
son successeur frédéric brun l'ump est
battue par le sans étiquette jean louis
andres son et loire toujours avec la
ville de tournus le maire sortant jean
legros divers gauche perd son siège
c'est claude roche udi ump qui remporte
le scrutin à cluny la gauche perd la
ville de cluny le sortant jean luc
delpech est battu par henri beugnot le
candidat divers droite réalise 44 4% des
suffrages au creusot réélection d'andré
billardon ps s'il gagne le scrutin face
au divers droite charles landry et puis
enfin la ville d'autun largement en tête
au premier tour et miré bertrand porte
la ville avec un peu plus de 51% des
voix merci elsa la saône et loire où
nous attend jérôme durain depuis et
mâcon responsables du parti socialiste
dans le département
jérôme durain bonsoir c'est pas une
soirée de joyeuses pour vous on n'entend
pas mal de villes qui bascule à droite
dans ce département de la saône-et-loire
c'est vrai effectivement c'est une très
mauvaise soirée pour le parti socialiste
et pour la gauche en saône et loire avec
un phénomène national et une
amplification du résultat du premier
tour
et puis de mauvaises nouvelles qui sont
liées aussi à des divisions locales à la
gauche résiste ce n'est pas le parti
socialiste qui gueule je pense à bourbon
lancy
mais à une candidate divers gauche
qu'elle les enseignements vous en tirez
notamment vu ce qu'est une forme de
prime à la diversité politique à gauche
et que ceux qui avait l'étiquette
politique du parti socialiste ont été
durement sanctionnés donc ça appelle
évidemment une réorientation politique
nationale on voit qu'un message très
fort qui a été adressé par les électeurs
donc je crois qu'il faut évidemment un
remaniement il faut un nouveau casting
et puis il faudrait orientations
politiques il faut entendre le message
que les électeurs ont fait passer ce
soir avec par endroits jérôme durain ne
se croit une difficulté à s'entendre
avec d'autres composantes de la gauche
exemple à cluny par exemple le total des
voix de gauche ce soir est supérieur à
celui du nouveau maire mais là vous avez
parlé fiez vous entendre il ya deux
endroits qui sont symptomatiques de ce
que vous dites c'est effectivement cluny
et louhans où le total gauche nous
permettait en théorie arithmétiquement
de l'emporter et effectivement
on voit la fin une victoire de la droite
donc la division nous coûte très cher
dans un contexte où il fallait savoir
s'unir et et porter nos couleurs
ensemble donc c'est un message qu'il va
falloir qu'on travaille et sur lequel il
va devoir méditer dans les jours à venir
merci jérôme durain en direct de mâcon
pour ses commentaires sur les résultats
en saône-et-loire faire agir nos invités
peut-être françois patriat d'abord sur
cette suite de la déroute du parti
socialiste je crois que ce soir le mur
du réel percute de plein fouet les
socialistes
je regrette d'avoir eu raison un peu tôt
quand je disais à mes amis cours des
mois dernier que ce serait pas un
scrutin local et qu'on n'échappera pas à
la règle
deux ans après une élection d'un d'une
difficulté dans un scrutin intermédiaire
je crois qu'à trois raisons ce soir à
l'échelle de la gauche le premier c'est
la date même de ce scrutin qui
intervient deux ans après une élection
présidentielle dont on a toujours vu
toujours vu dans les 30 dernières années
le parti au pouvoir
refluer par de cette intensité je leur
mère je regarde mes aux élections le
deuxième point c'est évidemment le
discrédit que connaît le gouvernement
actuellement et la faible cote de
popularité que connaît le chef de l'état
je crois que lui-même aujourd'hui à doit
comprendre qu'il est personnellement
visé la troisième raison c'est je crois
la capacité de la droite à mobiliser son
électorat en enlevant le côté local en
délocalisant le scrutin pour en faire un
scrutin national
je crois que ces trois facteurs réunis
peuvent expliquer pour partie le grave
échec de ce soir j'avais dit la semaine
dernière une déferlante pas une vague je
dis ce soir à tsunami surtout quand on
voit la carte en bourgogne
je pense à mes amis qui ce soir
connaissent des difficultés avec
quelques exceptions dijon auxerre mais
ces sont des candidats très implanté
c'était la seule solution pour résister
apparemment le fait de l'implantation
n'est pas la seule explication parce que
je pense que christophe sirugue à chalon
était bien implanté que didier mathus et
de l'implanter et bien de la planter
un manceau à montceau que mes amis de
neuvirth sainte fare garnot était très
bien implantée à nevers et qu'ils
avaient d'autres amis dans d'autres
territoires
je crois que ça a été la capacité à
mobiliser avait pas hésité à mobiliser
les bilans ont sans doute joué aussi des
jeux aussi
et puis par ailleurs la moindre
mobilisation ou de divisions avec le
front national en face pour ce qui
concerne l'opposition françois sauvadet
vous nous aviez dit vous nous aviez pas
réagi la semaine dernière
confirmation ce soir ce qui s'est passé
vous ça s'accentue en fait oui ben c'est
exactement c'est ce qu'on avait
enregistrées au premier tour des
élections s'est poursuivie au deuxième
tour pour le choix décisif
je crois que d'ailleurs françois patriat
vient de l'exprimer mais faut pas
oublier une chose c'est que c'est dans
ce sont d'abord des chants qui ont sont
allés voter et qui ont exprimé à un
mal-être et sur le sentiment d'avoir été
aussi c'est à dire qu'un des réseaux et
mélangez pas tout à fait l'analyse d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui nous
disent que voilà il ya de la
désaffection à l'égard du des élus je
pense que il faudra qu'on réfléchisse à
notre organisation institutionnelle
aujourd'hui les français ont le
sentiment que la seule élection qui
compte qui engage tout l'avenir pendant
cinq ans ces élections présidentielles
je crois qu'il faudra qu'on y
réfléchisse parce que toutes les autres
élections
vous n'avez qu'à voir de ce n'est pas
propre à cette élection si n'est ni à
désaveu parce qu'en fait les gens qui se
sont tout de même déplacés
en tout cas moi ce que j'observe c'est
que ceux qui se sont exprimés
nombreux ont adressé à carton c'est pas
comme l'a dit françois rebsamen à carte
rouge simplement pour des couacs au
gouvernement une organisation technique
qu'il faudrait faire avec des
professionnels plus chevronnés 7h les
français ont demandé un changement de
cap au chef de l'état
tout simplement parce que qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont payé pendant deux ans et demi
d'aborder deux ans et deux mois
des tas de promesses de campagne et puis
le résultat vous avez vu même entre les
deux tours la noms de dizaines de
milliers de chômeurs supplémentaires on
est pratiquement à trois millions et
demi de chômeurs le fait que le
gouvernement se défausse en arrêt sur
ses prédécesseurs en disant c'est de
leur faute ce pays va mal mais le pays
leur a donné toutes les manettes leur a
donné le sénat il leur a donné la
chambre des députés l'assemblée
nationale le président de la république
toutes les manettes donc c'est pas
gouvernement de l'impuissance qu'ils
attendaient or ils ont vu un
gouvernement qu à fracturer sur des
sujets de société
là où l'attendait un gouvernement de
concorde puisque c'est précisément
l'europe proche les à nicolas sarkozy un
gouvernement de concorde pour travailler
sur l'emploi et sur l'avenir de leur vie
tout simplement
mais moi je suis présente conseil
général aux premières lignes de cette
fracture sociale je la vis au quotidien
je suis pas surpris par ce qui se passe
par le vote des gens qui ont dit assez
nous avez trompés en maintenant il ya
des équipes en échec qui sont constitués
il ya du rajeunissement il ya du
renouvellement il ya eu aussi du
rassemblement pour dire stop stop à un
système comme idée auxerre et dijon
l'avertissement il est sévère aussi il
faut pas se tromper après que j'amène
toulon françois 100 monde me disait il
ya il ya trois semaines j'ouvrais les
journaux 70% dès le premier tour on le
voyait plebis et attendez moi aussi je
voudrais vous pour sortir les coupures
de presse tuca il allait faire un score
vraiment hallucinant dans sa version que
non seulement elle trébuchait mais qu'il
a fallu attendre le second tour et qu'au
final même si on a analysé les scrutins
il sera combien 52 53
on est loin du plébiscite annoncé à
auxerre c'est vrai que ferrer a gagné
milliken comment assembler attendait de
combien 300 voix donc on voit bien que
ça joue à happy note
en fait il ya une vague une vraie vague
et je crois aussi qu'ils auraient sa
cartouche sur des réformes dont on
parlera la réforme territoriale la
baisse des dotations tout ça va revenir
sur le tapis
et croyez-moi le gouvernement n'en a pas
fini avec des réformes qu'ils imposent
aux forceps
nous allons aussi à auxerre guy roux
l'arrivée nous attend battu par guy
férez ce soir bonsoir guillaume larrivé
on évoqué l'implantation du maire
socialiste est ce que c'est ça qui fait
la différence selon vous ce soir
moi je veux d'abord dire un très grand
merci à ces milliers
de serre oise et de ses rois qui me font
confiance
j'ai gagné 1200 voix par rapport à 2012
par rapport à l'élection du député la
dynamique a clairement était de mon côté
à la tête d'une belle équipe
il me manque en réalité 160 voix pour
faire la différence par rapport au
candidat socialiste ce soir c'est vrai
je suis triste pour auxerre car je
considère que cette victoire de monsieur
ferrer est une défaite pour auxerre mais
je reste comme député pleinement au
service des eaux sarroise et des
auxerrois bien sûr que si on dirait que
c'est qu est-ce que finalement c'est
justement pas ce mandat de député qui
vous empêche d'accéder à la mairie
d'auxerre les gens sont diaries va être
plus à l'assemblée nationale que chez
nous est ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est ça finalement qui paradoxalement a
été un handicap pour votre candidature
non écoutés quand on regarde très
précisément les choses on voit en
réalité que l'élection s'est jouée dans
dans deux quartiers de quartiers dans
lesquels le maire socialiste à mener je
le dis très directement ces derniers
jours une campagne haineuse à mon égard
une campagne ordurière qui je le crains
a malheureusement fait la différence
merci guillaume larrivé en direct
d'auxerre pour cette réaction va rester
dans l'yonne justement à quasiment 9h30
sur france 3 bourgogne
lionel a besoin avec de nouveaux
résultats oui elle avait dirigé la ville
de sens de 2001 à 2008 marie louise fort
se réinstalle dans son fauteuil de maire
elles totalisent près de 51% des
suffrages 20 points de plus que sa
rivale francine weecksteen sans
étiquette à auxerre guy ferrer on l'a
dit tout à l'heure garde la tête de sa
ville natale le socialiste l'emportent
de moins de 300 voix on vient d'en
parler tout de suite avec guillaume
larrivé dans l'yonne toujours tonnerre
bascule à droite dominique aguilar
divers droite s'impose face au
socialiste pascal lenoir dauphin d'
andré fourcade et puis enfin jouanny
reste à gauche
le maire sortant bernard moraine est
réélu avec 49% des suffrages l'ump
obtient 42 % des voix bernard moraine le
maire de joigny nous attend justement en
direct bonsoir bernard moraine
réélection rappelle qu'il y avait une
très longue
lire avec le front national présent dans
votre ville ce soir ben oui et puis
finalement on a repoussé le front
national qui était à près de 12 et demi
pour cent au premier tour et qui est ce
soir à 8% et on remporte 7
cette victoire ça fait vraiment du bien
on a donné tout ce qu'on avait on a
présenté un joli bilan qui était
difficile dans une ville comme vous le
savez qui a été victime de la rgpp de la
fermeture de sa caserne en particulier
qui est une ville en souffrance et on va
pouvoir terminer le travail qu'on a
commencé sur ces six prov prochaines
années
bonsoir bernard moraine est ce que le
fait de ne pas avoir d'étiquette parti
socialiste dans le dos était un avantage
pour vous dans cette élection il en jeu
vous faire un scoop je suis de gauche et
je suis un maire shameer ouvert à tout
le monde
je suis un maire 2100 jours c'est ça
c'est la durée d'un mandat ou je suis
auprès de la population je parle à tout
le monde
j'ai mes convictions j'ai mes valeurs je
les ai toujours défendu
je crois que ce sont surtout des valeurs
d'humanisme et oui je suis de gauche
mais j'ai été aussi capable de
rassembler des gens qui n'était pas de
gauche et on va travailler tous ensemble
pour mouiller le maillot de l'équipe de
jonnhy et on le disait tout à l'heure
vous avez été élu la première fois à la
faveur d'un déchirement de la droite
comment finalement avez vous réussi à
vous implanter dans cette ville de
joigny qui traditionnellement votre
quand même plus à droite c'est je sais
pas c'est je crois que c'est le tracé le
travail c'est le travail au quotidien
savoir s'entourer de d'élus avec une
équipe sort landes sortante qui était
d'une grande qualité et celle qui va
rentrer samedi prochain va être encore
de meilleure qualité
c'est des gens de terrain de tous les
quartiers de toutes les conditions
j'allais dire de de toutes les couleurs
aussi et ça c'est ma fierté
et puis d'être à l'écouté des jeux
vignes 1 c'est pas par hasard et c'est
même étonnant dans le père dans le
paysage politique en général ce sont les
opposants qui font plein de propositions
et bien c'est nous les sortants qui
avons proposé un programme de 120
propositions et qu'on va mettre en
oeuvre
dans les prochaines années la ville de
joigny qui restent à gauche donc ce soir
on l'a bien compris avec vous bernard
moraine merci d'avoir été en duplex
depuis sans ce nous restons dans l'yonne
tout de suite avec guy ferrer
le maire sortant a d'auxerre réélu ce
soir donc nous avons entendu votre
challenger guillaume larrivé tout à
l'heure il évoqué une campagne ordurière
ces derniers jours une campagne tout
court pour vous guy ferrer écoutez moi
j'ai connu j'ai conduit une campagne qui
est une campagne propre par définition
d'abord parce que c'est dans la nature
et les jours fait revivre en campagne
électorale du plus pur respect de mes
adversaires j'ai envie de dire à
guillaume larrivé que quand on est
perdant on doit être grand seigneur
c'est la règle en la matière comment
vous expliquez vous que vous ayez réussi
à résister à cette vague de dans le pays
parce que vous allez aimer quand le vent
du boulet comme on disait tout à l'heure
c'est très juste cette victoire le vent
du boulet je les ai sentis gelé senti
ces derniers mois je l' ai senti ces
dernières semaines mais je crois et je
rebondis sur ce que disait bernard
moraine lorsque les choses vont mal il
reste quelques points de repères et
auxerre est resté sous la conduite est
resté d'une certaine manière un repère
pour les auxerrois c'est le travail
quotidien c'est le travail de tous les
jours et c'est aussi cette capacité je
crois tout simplement entendre à écouter
et dans un contexte national qui est
n'écoute pas visiblement suffisamment et
bien à travers ce qu'on me dit il ya
beaucoup de villes perdues aujourd'hui
par les socialistes heures bourgogne je
crois que dijon et auxerre ont résisté
et bien tant mieux c'est une qualité dé
beir qui dirige cette ville ces villes
bon soit différent lilian melet est-ce
que vous avez dû laisser en route un
certain nombre de projets un certain
nombre de choses dans cette campagne est
ce que ça va influer on va dire la
difficulté de campagne va influer sur
votre mandat à venir au nom sur les
projets que j'ai présentées aux
auxerrois et bien nous allons continuer
d'abord il ya des projets a terminé il y
aura d'autres à venir à partir du moment
où j'ai été élu et bien ses projets d'où
vous reçoivent la b diddy t2 les
concitoyens
en revanche ce que je
vraiment cette campagne a été âpre elle
était dure elle a été difficile et bien
plus que jamais sans doute le maire que
je suis là aussi dans un contexte
difficile
il me revient en quelque sorte de
recoller un certain nombre de choses à
certains nombre de cicatrices
c'est ce à quoi je vais m'employer et
souci tout simplement ce qui me motive
d'une manière remarquable pour ce
troisième mandat recoudre les choses
pour autant que les ip être déchirés
durant tout rond le long de cette
campagne troisième mandat donc pour vous
guy férez merci d'avoir été en direct
depuis auxerre ce soir sur france 3
bourgogne des résultats à 21h35 la
nièvre avec un rappel de résultats elle
a besoin
mais avec ce gros résultat à la ville de
nevers ce coup de tonnerre denis thuriau
s'emparent de ce fief socialiste depuis
et 43 ans une ville-symbole ancienne
ville de pierre bérégovoy denis thuriau
totalise 49 8% des suffrages
varennes vauzelles le parti communiste
perd cette ville dans la nièvre de peu
26 voix d'écart entre isabelle bonicel
divers droite et pascal reuillard pcf
et puis enfin un gros plan sur clamecy
claudine boisorieux divers gauche est
réélu avec une voix d'avancé devant le
ps michel car voyeur en 2008 elle avait
été réélue avec une poignée de voix
également les liens manette wii alors
varennes-vauzelles on n'a pas dit tout à
l'heure parce qu'on parlait beaucoup de
nos verts mais effectivement c'est
extrêmement symbolique parce que c'est
une perte pour parti communiste pascal
reuillard c'est quelqu'un qui compte
dans la nièvre
la musique c'est la deuxième de la
région après me gêne mais c'est aussi la
preuve des difficultés extrêmes entre le
parti socialiste et globalement le parti
communiste
jérôme durain parlais tout à l'heure des
difficultés qu'à eues à cluny il y avait
plus de voix de gauche
là il ya la même chose et puis c'est
passé un phénomène qui ressemble un peu
à celui de nos verts puisque le candidat
de l'ump s'est retiré il aurait pu être
au deuxième tour il s'est retiré
et là il ya un total de voix qui lui en
revanche un report qui s'est extrêmement
bien fait un mot en revanche aussi sur
clamecy où ça se joue trois voies deux
voix une voix
c'est absolument incroyable claudine
boisorieux les plus au parti socialiste
depuis un certain temps le parti
socialiste était revenu à la charge pour
lui prendre la ville michel quint voyeur
c'est le secrétaire du parti socialiste
à clamecy est à nouveau et la remontée à
retard parce que c'était la même chose
en 2008 et donc c'est vraiment une ville
très particulière clamecy et le parti
socialiste l'a aussi michel carrière il
avait une étiquette socialiste et donc
n'a pas réussi à reprendre la ville
retour sur la situation à nevers à
présent la nièvre où nous attend
guillaume maillard
c'est la liste donc de donner thuriau
qui gagne ce soir la mairie de nevers
avec votre soutient guillaume maillard
pour lui dit alors denis thuriau nous
expliquer que la ville de nevers ne
bascule et pas à droite mais élections
avec donc le soutien de l'ump de lui dit
votre analyse votre version votre vision
même si je vois que denis therriault
terre encore derrière vous donc pour a
confirmé ce que vous allez dire et vous
parler sous son contrôle et j'allais
dire sous son contrôle bonsoir à tous je
suis pas sûr qu'on peut parler de
contrôle on a eu un beau combat
politique inverse il y avait cette liste
premier tour nous avons mené notre
propre projet nous avons su nous
entendre derrière un projet commun le
projet de nos verres à venir c'est un
c'est une victoire pour un projet pour
une pluralité pour
un projet de ville simplement peut-être
que nous devrions peut-être plus souvent
revenir vers ses fondamentaux municipaux
la ville de varennes vauzelles uni et
d'en parler a également changé ce soir
autour du nist également fédératrice
sans étiquette c'est peut-être là une
nouvelle voie de coalition je dirais ou
d'union autour d'un projet qui qui qui
arrive ce soir en tout cas 43 ans de
socialisme à nevers je pense que tout le
monde était d'accord pour dire qu'il
fallait engager nos verts sur une
nouvelle dynamique qui est nous avons su
prouver ou non vers soi que nous avions
ses ambitions je suis un citoyen avant
d'être un homme politique je suis chef
d'entreprise on a des on a des
compétences les uns et les autres et on
va les mettre en oeuvre pour arriver à
mener nos verts vers sète cette nouvelle
ère guillaume maillard donc denis
therriault nous disait tout à l'heure
vous allez c'est vous avez laissé vous
de votre étiquette un peu à la porte en
vous mettant sur sa liste est ce que ça
veut dire que vous laisser aussi les
valeurs de l'ue 10 à la porte
en rentrant sur cette liste et
s'intéressera notamment françois
sauvadet qui sur ce plateau
bonsoir françois absolument pas je suis
je suis dans la famille udi j'en suis
fier j'ai mené les élections cantonales
en 2011 sur le canton de clères
bérégovoy nous avions fait un très beau
score
jean luc martinât en 2008 avait mené le
combat pour les municipales on voit
qu'au premier tour lui d y progresse de
4 points par rapport au score au score
des législatives donc on voit qu'il ya
une nette progression de notre famille
politique au sein de nevers après il
était nécessaire de mettre en en bémol
nos étiquettes politiques autour de ce
projet de rassemblement si nous voulions
gagner à nevers puisque l'ambition
c'était quelque part un référendum pour
ou contre le maire sortant et son
système
je pense qu'on a tous été intelligent et
on a tous décidé ensemble de gagner
maintenant les ti cats udi m'appartient
je suis allé dans mon coeur et on va
travailler pour les prochaines échéances
il valeur des cantonales des régionales
des législatives il ya un mouvement qui
se créent nous avons tout notre
autonomie
par contre au sein du conseil municipal
je serai un élu nevers à venir aux côtés
de denis et j'en suis très fier merci
guillaume maillard en direct de nevers
donc la liste de denis thériault qui
arrive en tête et qui donc décroche la
mairie de nevers et cette situation
intéresse au premier chef françois
sauvadet pour lui d alors faut-il
enlever l'étiquette u10 pour être sûr de
marquer des points françois sauvadet
non mais il est bon est ce que voulait
la victoire à gérer soutenir moi je suis
très ambitieux soutenu il était candidat
j'ai dit oui je sais bien mais gégé
j'étais de ceux qui ont plaidé
d'ailleurs sur votre plateau je suis pas
sûr en souvenez la semaine dernière sur
votre plateau j'ai appelé les trois
listes à s'unir pour faire en sorte
qu'ils une alternative à nevers de
nevers en fait c'est la fin d'un système
là bas les gens ne pouvaient plus enfin
une espèce de transmission de flambeau
permanente manque de respiration une
ville reine qui a perdu huit mille
habitants une douzaine d'années
mentionné sur place enfin franchement il
y avait une inspiration changement il
fallait rendre le changement possible et
donc nous avons rendu le changement
possible et moi chaque fois qu on se
rassemblera autour d'un projet pour
rendre le changement possible de
préparer des conditions d'une alternance
politique
je serai là pour les aider pour
l'accompagner dois vous dire j'ai tout
fait pour cette fusion donc donc vous
revendiquez l'objecteur d'ironie s non
je ne revendique pas d'abord c'est la
victoire de denis thuriau et toute sa
liste
moi je dis bravo denis courage continuez
ouvrez donner de l'air un peu et de la
respiration adverse en a bien besoin
mettez de l'économie au coeur de tout
cela est en tout cas s'être c'est plein
de promesses pour l'avenir des neuf et
reçoit j'en suis convaincu françois
patriat
une remarque sur le
chut on va dire de l'ovaire chez daunat
vers effectivement c'est comme la
chaussée à gauche c'est comme
aujourd'hui la chute de limoges c'est
comme la chute de dunkerque c'est comme
la chute de toulouse c'est comme la
chute de montceau ce soir ce sont des
défaites brutale fait brutal c'est
d'abord à nevers le prix d'une division
je pense aussi que 1 9 heures on pense
que la gauche était installée pour
l'éternité
peut-être peut-être la mobilisation
n'at-elle pas été au rendez vous
pourtant je pense que florent sainte
fare garnot août à ta mère qui était à
la fois à la fois brillant avec une
vision pour sa ville
je suis pas assez impliqué dans la dans
la vie de versoise pour le voir
peut-être peut-être une trop grande
confiance et peut-être la certitude que
la nièvre serait toujours à gauche
or il n'y a aucun bastion toujours à
gauche toujours à droite on a vu de
telles surprises dernières années que là
aussi tout pouvait arriver mais moi je
regrette d'avoir été un peu prophètes de
malheur en disant que j'avais les pires
craintes
j'avais les pires craintes portent le
nez tu allais dire comme pour louhans
pour tourner pour mon saut je t'avais
pas pour nevers c'est vrai qu'il ya des
choses qu'on pense que évidemment
comprendre qu'ils peuvent pas arriver
celle là elle vient par a fait une
longue liste de défaite douloureuse
je crois que la gauche ce soir peut
reprocher faute d'avoir pas politiser le
débat la droite la politiser comme nous
l'avons fait nous par le passé la gauche
n'a pas voulu le politiser
elle a refusé de débattre argument
contre argument en voulant localiser le
débat je crois que ce soir elle en paye
le prix fort isabelle de almeida nous a
rejoints on va là ça le bon soir soir le
parti communiste le front de gauche
était candidate front de gauche sur la
ville de dijon on évoquera le situation
de dijon d'ailleurs avec un résultat
dans les effectifs définitifs voilà on y
va tout de suite retrouvé
emmanuel pinsonneault pour ce résultat
donc attendu sur la ville de dijon chaix
êtes nombreux à vouloir ce résultat
emmanuel personne ou à ton ce résultat
définitif sur dijon oui cette fois on
l'a et c'est confirmé françois rebsamen
entame donc ce soir un troisième mandat
à la mairie de dijon il est réélu avec
52 8% des voix
34% pour alain houpert le front national
de chars edouard cas d'un le recueil
13,1 pour cent des suffrages résultats
également sur talent ou gilbert menut le
maire sortant est réélu avec 45 9% des
suffrages
le divers droite cyrille gaucher est le
candidat de gauche et stéphane
woynaroski sont presque à égalité de
voix seulement les séparent ils sont à
27 % tous les deux et enfin à chenôve le
maire sortant jean et mona est réélu
avec 41 2% des suffrages
roland ponsâa recueille 38% et philippe
chaix ravate 20,6 pour cent des
suffrages
merci emmanuel dijon justement ça
s'agite me semble-t-il sur les réseaux
sociaux vous suivez cette élection sur
france 3 bourgogne sur internet via
twitter également f3 bourgogne théo ce
moment que peut-on lire en ce moment ah
oui pardon justement et bien christophe
taristas assiste en ce moment même à la
conférence de presse de françois
rebsamen et il vient de tweets et ce
petit message on citant françois
rebsamen un remaniement point
d'interrogation
je n'ai pas de contacts mais je
réfléchis comprenne qui pourra
et sinon sur dijon également un message
posté par david lalo du grès candidat
qui n'était pas qualifié pour le second
tour a dit jean il ya eu deux gagnants
mois au premier tour et françois
rebsamen pour le deuxième tour il m'a
félicité au premier je le félicite
au deuxième sportif et puis deux
messages de responsables socialistes
dans la région gaëtan gorce d'abord qui
tout était bien maintenant il reste à
reconstruire retrouver le goût des idées
et pour s'être certains ré apprendre
l'humilité
et puis autre message posté par safia
otokoré vice-présidente du conseil
régional de bourgogne ps également un
vrai tsunami en bourgogne tristesse les
électeurs ont exprimé un changement de
cap le gouvernement doit les écouter
continuer à réagir vous voyez vous un
message à s'afficher en bas d'écran a
régulièrement offertes à gérer d'amendé
invité comme isabelle de almeida
puisqu'on vient d'avoir le résultat de
dijon allez on voit pas on vous a vu
faire une drôle de tête quand on a
entendu le tweet de david lebon degrés
oui je vais pas commenter le critt degré
chance pas qu'on est là pour ça ce soir
sur dix jours un résultat week était à
la hauteur des attentes 1 et c'est une
bonne chose moi j'essaie plus la
situation dans le pays en bourgogne
évidemment dans le département et dans
le pays qui m'inquiète gravelines désert
pour parti communiste me gêne on me dit
varennes-vauzelles aussi oui mais rien
ne vaut l1 donc oui ont entraîné y
compris les villas direction communiste
entraînée par part par le désaveu par
rapport au gouvernement un chemin de
voir un tweet qui appelle un changement
de cap je pense que oui il faut un
changement de cap à gauche
comment la barre à gauche la barre à
gauche oui parce qu'on voit bien que les
électeurs même si pour pour certains on
pouvait penser que c'était les enjeux
locaux qu'elle est primé mais dans la
tête des gens les enjeux locaux istis
eux ils se mélangent avec leur vie leur
vie quotidienne
donc évidemment qu'à sanction par
rapport à la politique gouvernementale
et le remaniement ministériel
on peut être est ce qui sera fait demain
je ne sais pas nana n'êtes pas né n'est
pas sérieux par rapport à la halle à
comment la halle attentes des gens de
mesures qu'ils soient qui favorise le
bien-être quotidien
il ya un marqueur de cette élection
c'est quand même où le disais
précédemment les difficultés à
s'entendre à dire que julian de la
gauche a quand même vécu et les
difficultés à s'entendre jérôme durain
l'avait dit sur un certain nombre de
villes alors c'était le camp sud loire
c'était le cas dans la nuit
puisque varennes-vauzelles d'une liste
ps europe écologie face à pascal
reuillard c'est quoi ça veut dire que
vous vous entendez plus que le parti
socialiste non je pense qu'il ya eu un
appel
la fabricant d'hiver qu'à dijon alors
françois rebsamen et équipements là on
est sur un deuxième tour donc il ya eu
un appel de la part du parti communiste
a à se rassembler à gauche pour battre
la droite et l'extrême droite
je regrette mois que à certaines ombres
à certains endroits ce n'est pas pu être
fait et que de ce fait là il ya défaite
et la défaite de la gauche qu'elle soit
à direction socialiste europe écologie
les verts ou communistes en même temps
on constate quand même aussi des
alliances contre nature y compris dans
notre dans notre région ce qu'on vient
de voir à nevers on voit aussi à chenôve
et moi je me félicite du résultat de la
liste chenôve ville d'avenir des
alliances contre nature qui dépolitise
le débat et qui font que les gens ne
n'arrive pas avoir de repères entre
entre une politique de gauche une
politique de droite donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment la reprendre les choses
pas à zéro mais vraiment niveau où elles
sont et puis et puis rencontrer les gens
mené débat politique oui j'ai pu que
c'est qu'il le disait reprenons le
chemin de du débat d'idées et ne faisons
pas comme si les choses étaient
installés que les gens se satisferait de
gestion de leur ville même cote c'est
bien meilleur des critiques
et voilà il faut que c'est du sens
politique la gestion d'une commune com
de com d'un territoire
la grande tendance c'était le sans
étiquette la mode de cette année celle
sans étiquette
françois patriat et et françois sauvadet
une réaction quand même ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les partis c'est
fini ce que denis curie gagne sans
étiquette un très clairement il l'a dit
même si vous venez d o maillard mais oui
le côté sans étiquette j'ai observé que
les deux surtout à gauche à omar sy
socialiste claude jeunes en fait il y
avait des listes d'alternance
d'alternative politique
alors pour gauche alors si ça trompe
personne pourquoi est ce que ces
candidats se sont battu pied à pied avec
nous pendant toute la campagne
oui pour obtenir de ne pas étiqueter
politiquement bush pas un coûteux faudra
leur poser la question à part un mois
simplement ce que je vous dis c'est que
à nevers personne n'a arrangé ces
étiquettes on n'est pas arrivé masqué on
n'était pas le combat des chevalier
masqué je veux dire guillaume maillard
que je suis et soutenir été clairement
udi
enfin voilà alors qu'il en est certain
il est certain qu'il est mais je pense
que c'était plus généralisé pour la
gauche et notamment pour le ps ou même
moi j'ai vu qu'on y compris à dijon
jeanne impulsif fonction affirmé
l'exercer encore des responsables
nationale étaient présents du groupe c
du scénario mais franchement non mais
attendez la masse sur le cac s'était dit
jiang dijon joie déjà que ça doit
changer puisqu'il commence à regarder du
côté de paris dès son élection
enfin bon bref tout ça c'est la
politique mais ce qui reste c'est que il
ya eu des stratégies d' alternatives
proposées parfois avec à la place en
bleu mende en déplaise à certains ce
dont je me réjouis pour créer
précisément les conditions de
l'alternance parce que les gens veulent
que ça change
la dernière chose sur moi je voudrais
saluer aussi tout ce qu'on fait des
campagnes à fond moi j'ai été aussi
partout dans le département de lakota
on a gagné dans de très nombreuses
villes parce qu'on avait aussi de très
bons candidats
avec il est vrai une capacité à
rassembler c'est ça qui compte
quand les gens sont si déboussolés
désorientés qui attendent attentes
ce qu'ils veulent c'est des hommes et
des femmes qui rassemble autour d'eux
donc quand j'entendais monsieur perez
pas franchement nous dire que c'était la
victoire de ce qui était bien implanté
qui a bien travaillé ses petits
camarades du ps qui ont perdu dans
toutes les villes de bourgogne je pense
qu'ils vont apprécier le message parce
que il y en a quand même qui avait fait
du travail simplement ils ont été
balayés dans une vague d'une ampleur
forte et j'ai à dire sans précédent
depuis de nombreuses années et alors du
coup la rippe la rectrice la réponse
c'est être plutôt une prime la
dissidence mais remarqué que les
dissidents sont intervenus et sont
souvent des problèmes de personnes on
l'a vu à chez nous on l'a vu à autun on
l'a vu dans plusieurs endroits où c'est
la dissidence qui l'emportait à des
finances parce que il y avait des
accords deux personnes pas
fondamentalement un désaccord d'idées
mais c'est plus facile en période
difficile de cacher un peu son étiquette
tu vois bien que certains l'ont fait je
ne sais pas sûr que tous les codecs
audio à bourbon-lancy nous pour cet
exemple lorsqu'elles alors là encore
c'est un problème de personnes
exactement voilà c'est un problème entre
le maire sortant et adjointe qui devenu
grâce au ps
grâce au ps même dissidente soutenue par
le ps député qui aujourd'hui se retourne
contre son maire on voit bien que c'est
sans étiquette sont plus des problèmes
de
c'est à dire de choix de dissidence
locales que de 10 lens nationale non
c'est vrai que quand on est parti au
pouvoir que les choses vont mal que
c'est difficile moi je préfère le projet
du passé on pourrait tous se relancer à
la figure les chiffres du chômage dans
le dernier quinquennat
les chiffres de la croissance les
chiffres de la dette tout le monde peut
le faire moi je ne suis pas dans ce
récit ce soir nous elle risque un parti
au gouvernement qui assume ce soir qui
assume ce soir et choix difficiles qu'il
a fait et qui le fait dans quelles
conditions
et là il a pris des mesures ce
gouvernement moi j'en ai soutenu
plusieurs au sénat mais tout ce qui a
fait de bien a été occulté par trois
choses le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir
d'achat le chômage et les impôts
ces trois facteurs clés qui ont dominé
la campagne qui ont retenu de la
nationalisation du scrutin et qui ont
fait la différence
et alors comment réagir en parlant
remaniement rapide il faut que ce soit
rapide il faut resserrer les rangs en
effet de souffle et de choc
la semaine dernière vous dites je vous
disais il faut d'abord de la pédagogie
je crois qu'il serait bon de rappeler
une fois pour toutes quelle est la
situation de la france je vous rappelle
quand même que les imports d'aujourd'hui
sur la d 10 1
c'est clair on dire pour le rappelle que
l'école et le choix pour la france
quel choix quelle politique en
expliquant bien avec quels sont les
enjeux quels sont les risques
la france peut-elle voir toutes et tous
ces chiffres dégradé peut le voir sa
dette augmenter
peut-elle voir le chômage monte non elle
doit prendre des mesures et mesure que
l'ajout de monde et l'europe la semaine
prochaine je crois que changement de cap
c'est difficile ce qu'il faut c'est sans
doute de nouvelles équipes avec deux
dents de l'autorité un sens de l'état de
la discipline et un cap clair des jeux
un effet de choc et de souffle avant de
retrouver francine weecksteen on va dire
encore une fois que c'était qu'il n'a
pas assez expliqué que c'était la faute
du gouvernement précédent
enfin je sais pas ça va tromper personne
ça fait deux ans et deux mois deux ans
et envie jour quinze jours deux ans et
deux mois
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas trouvé beaucoup
pendant la campagne défense d'un
gouvernement et des réformes qui ont été
engagées pas beaucoup moins en tout cas
je les ai pas entendus
troisième extrait nous attend va le
retrouver dans un petit instant des
résultats avec vous elle a besoin oui
trois résultats à chevigny saint sauveur
michel rogers ump est élu avec 51% des
voix devant le socialiste louis legrand
31% et le
vers droite j'en perd 1 16% à chenôve
réélection de jean et mona il conserve
son siège avec 41 2% des suffrages c'est
deux points de plus que son ancien
adjoint le dissident roland ponsâa et on
termine avec quétigny michel bachelard
socialiste est réélu avec 55% des
suffrages accord interline en
médicaments pour chenôve pour dire que
le candidat de l'ump c'est qu'ils
arrivent en quatrième position s'était
retiré pour faire barrage au front
national
ça a surtout fait monter le front
national de plus de deux points qui a 20
soit 26,1 chesneau donc l'opération
barrages pas sûr que c'était vraiment
compris voilà bien compris à victor au
premier tour à gevrey chambertin
on avait oublié ce soir aussi avec de
belles victoires qui s'était passé un
peu inaperçu et venarey les laumes
venarey les laumes interne à l'ombre qui
vous accompagneront la nie pas ce soir
votre francine weecksteen qui nous
attend depuis un petit moment maintenant
en direct de sang de bonsoir et merci
d'avoir patienté notre réaction marius
ford ont créé lui ce soir à sens votre
commentaire
bah je la félicite évidemment puisque ce
sont les électeurs qui ont décidé
qu'elle soit le prochain maire de sens
je revendique clairement je vous ai
entendu tout à l'heure par les
soviétiques avaient pu partir sans
étiquette
donc moi je revendique clairement ce
positionnement sans étiquette politique
ce positionnement je les construis
depuis plusieurs mois avec des personnes
qui ont sont ont été autour de moi dans
cette liste du bon sens des personnes de
droite de gauche du centre et j'ai eu
l'habitude de dire que j'étais ni de
droite ni de gauche que j'étais devant
aujourd'hui effectivement je suis
derrière marie louise fort mais avec 33
pour presque 33 % des deux voies avec
2700 personnes qui est derrière moi se
sont reconnus dans un projet qui était
basée sur l'intérêt général un projet où
le plus important était laissée donné
les celanese aujourd'hui manifestement
c'est encore difficile dans une ville de
25000 habitants de 2
gagner la mairie sans étiquette
politique le poids des partis est encore
prépondérant le poids de l'ump a été
important dans cette élection le poids
du fn également voilà aujourd'hui je
suis fier d'avoir conduit avec l'équipe
qui m'a entourait depuis plusieurs mois
cette cette aventure je sais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est possible de vous
faire de la politique autrement de la
politique basée sur l'intérêt général
sur le souci de répondre aux problèmes
des habitants et des habitantes et je
continue cet engagement parce que je
sais qu'il répond à une majorité des
décès données cenonnaise je sais aussi
que c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen de
ré de réconcilier les habitants avec la
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui à sens il
ya presque 40 9 % d'abstentionnistes
et ça n'est pas marie louise fort a été
élu avec la moitié des voix
le car même avec 25% des des suffrages
des habitants donc on ne peut pas se
réjouir de ce taux d'abstention aussi
important merci francine weecksteen en
direct de sens arriver donc deuxièmes
derrière marie louise fort eric sicaud
oui comme l'émission va se terminer
quand même une question à françois
patriat et françois sauvadet le le sénat
basculé en septembre
écoutez avec son catastrophique pour la
gauche avec des municipales aussi
catastrophique
le problème de la majorité au sénat va
se poser je n'ai pas fait le compte
aujourd'hui parce que vous savez que le
mode du scrutin a changé donc ça doit
amener une correction par ailleurs il
est certain que la majorité au sénat mme
sue ne semble aujourd'hui à moi
gravement menacée et avec des
difficultés supplémentaires pour
vous-même en côte d'or on verra les
semaines qui viennent
on se souvient déjà peaufiné bah oui je
suis d'accord sur la conclusion des
ponceaux plâtrier le sénat va basculer
oui je le pense enfin tout cas je
l'espère est ce que ça vous intéresse
ben vous mourrez vitrines contenant du
conseil général et responsable de l'udd
et au plan national vice président vous
éviterez les partis centristes sont très
importants au sénat réinviter moi je
viendrai avec bonheur en revanche parce
qu'on parle des municipales à la
houppette et sénateurs oui est sénateur
est-ce que de votre point de vue
sa défaite sur dijon le rend toujours
légitime pour les prochaines
sénatoriales où le disqualifie il a mené
un combat difficile a mené
courageusement s'était pas commode
on le voit bien la victoire a été
annoncée de telle manière est une façon
tellement récurrente qu'elle semblait
inévitable
en tout cas voilà il a fait son score on
pour le reste je poursuis mon sénateurs
les petits scores quand même pour dijon
la bbc cite du tout vouloir qu'on
analyse tout cela met enfin en tout cas
moi ce qui m'inquiète surtout c'est la
radicalisation du débat dans dijon parce
que c'est l'émergence du front national
à dijon c'est ça qui nous préoccupe
parce qu'on le voit bien par rapport au
dernier scrutin
est ce que c'est la sq ordinaire de nos
scores du maire de dijon disons le tout
net il est élu on voit là les dijonnais
ont choisi très bien c'est la démocratie
moi je respecte le choix rhin ce sera
dès demain mon interlocuteur au conseil
général naturellement mais je dis
simplement il était réélu par la hauteur
de ce qu'on annonçait 52 % quand on est
maire sortant avec une telle
implantation soi-disant dans sa ville
c'est quand même pas c'est pas le score
béton qu'on annonçait va vu quelques
chefs 5600 voit ses volumes de voix qui
ressemble à la quand même à 2008
oui ben voilà pas très bien vous avez
vous fait des commentaires positifs
commentaires du commentaire que je dis
c'est pas une victoire quand même aussi
éclatante qui est annoncé pour ce qui
est de notre score moi je regrette et je
constate avec amertume parce que c'est
vous savez le combat j'ai toujours mené
pour des valeurs je regrette la
radicalisation du débat politique à
dijon et la montée du front qui fera qui
sera présent à dijon et probablement au
grand dijon et ça je le regrette
profondément
ça demandera une analyse un peu plus
fine mais là aussi vous réaliserez pour
que je vous fasse le commentaire si vous
souhaitez enfants
je serai invité qu'un jour on parlera
bourgogne vous en avait déjà parlé tous
les deux sur un platane ans parle
souvent
merci à tous les trois d'être venu et de
revenir en a pris les rendez vous ce
soir le carnet est remplie merci
françois patriat isabelle de almeida et
pour cela des noms pour le sénat vous
viendrez sur france 3 nous annoncez vos
intentions c'est noté pour l'instant
j'ai rien annoncer du tout je vais
rentrer dans mon bureau conseil général
on l'a piégé conduit les deux
travaillent aussi investi connaître et à
tous on continue dans un petit quart
d'heure à décortiquer ces résultats en
bourgogne bourgogne point france 3 point
fr tout de suite carole gaessler et
francis letellier pour un retour sur la
synthèse nationale de ces municipales à
tout à l'heure